so the guy is yelling at a stock he's
like we're good don't box temper stop
parting at the birth dogs like um I'm a
dog you didn't it's bird that's what I
do
why people in LA are so insane about
their dogs
and then there's a bird in the tree was
like Thank You metric a member that's
real life
bravo Bravo absolute Bravo hey Luke hey
uh you know what that was just to make
the way you told that story it was like
she she was eating out of the palm of
your hand that's amazing
uh thank you Luke Sato
from broken family that show was my
childhood oh god you know I really
enjoyed your dog walking story I hope
you don't mind I was I wasn't even
trying to eavesdrop it was just the way
you said it
it was just like gripping like a
documentary I was watching but what's
your name is I'm scary okay my name is
Gary yeah you can change it if you
wanted no why would I change it are you
a sea Falcon how the could you know
that man oh the UH
yeah are you Leung I I'm not an online I
actually know but I banged a waitress
that went there once no that's actually
pretty cool oh god you're butting in
you're butting in and but it is cool she
butt in but she's actually right he's
very cool that's really great
how's the acting going Gary how did you
know I was an actor Luke you are like
low-key magical I know I don't believe
in magic
maybe she believes in magic which is
very stupid but I don't believe in magic
I do believe in deductive reasoning and
I deduce that you didn't just come here
from Iowa all the way to LA to sell
rocks
you can't ever did ah oh yeah no yeah no
she'll get my usual yes yeah the jiminy
plans this weekend no I've
like a loser okay well look I did this
thing at my house it's very casual it's
a charade night yeah we get together we
play games but you tell such good
stories that I figure that you could
come in and kind of like secretly be my
ringer are you inviting me to your
charades party oh my okay yeah okay bye
calm down
I love Midwesterners I always feel like
you could trust Midwesterners and you're
a what you're a what rubra no midwestern
yes you can trust people from the
Midwest but you can trust me
Luke 100% I am full on Midwest here let
me get your number just so I don't okay
of course I'm not gonna give you my
number but I'm gonna give you my third
email and that goes right to my second
assistant so there you go awesome here's
your soul scrub right double honey sack
no lemon stage add on buckwheat
pineapple shavings and Alumnus double
honey suck my dick double honey suck my
dick how are you
bright lights
dude come on bro
broken family was my favorite show I
grew up watching it Luke say toes like a
brother to me dude I know it was a
brother to all of us but it's just this
is a huge deal for my career all right
look you can't this up Rick I gotta
buy from him that he might want to like
mentor me and take me under his wing you
gotta bring me you can't roll solo dude
that's just lame and creepy yeah that's
a weird look okay but you would have to
promise me that a you wouldn't get
wasted no be no snapchatting of course
not and see most importantly do not
bring up the autoerotic asphyxiations
scandal that spiraled him and forced him
into rehab was all over the press of
course not dude done okay you can go go
yes broken family putting the pieces
back together again
Oh Sunday at 8:00 looks at out hey hey
what's up who's this sexy actor all
right oh it's my best friend Rick he's
not an actor
it is an honor to meet you sir hey at
ease lieutenant Rick anyway this is my
girlfriend Alicia
Richman is the one who said it's from
town USA oh no I actually said a
Ville USA sweetheart that's Gary
I'm Rick he's my ringer what's your
story
me oh no I'm just here for moral support
and I trained Gary in martial arts
yeah oh god you know what that's so cool
Gary I wish when I first moved out here
that my friends came with me because
it's not tough in the business yeah it's
good to have that support I mean I ended
up bunking with Robert Downey jr. and
Brad Pitt but whatever that's all in the
past anyway
you want a beer Rick three please um do
you think I could get a selfie with you
real quick
yeah yeah for sure Oh oh it was on
video oh yeah
Rick eat it no that's cool yeah do you
think you could repost that for me no
it's okay Joe uh you know what yeah you
know what I'll repost it and how about I
follow you too
huh I'll follow you on Instagram cool
let's go get you those three beers come
on let's do it
Apollo 13 pakal's I'll eat the movie um
uh yeah wait for Harper yes
Eat Pray Love obviously he's good it's
not it was just really easy all right
look it doesn't matter okay uh Gary your
turn the ringers up come on yeah get him
okay all right okay here we go all right
I'll get one pass right I'm gonna pass
on this one yeah let me go what come on
you're not gonna pass it would leo pass
Leo wouldn't pass so what would Leo do
come on
what would Leo do come on leo
okay gary mode okay King Kong Oh planet
Apes um I don't know what is the P
people oh that's it good good fellas
good haha okay hmm hmm gorillas in the
mist
uh Robocop Krispies
Oh x-men Oh what's that movie with the
Congo Congo symbols your monkey on
Ashley you're on acid acid ty story
it was Toy Story toys I didn't want to
do it I said I didn't want to do it
that's why I want to pass I said I said
that okay well uh yeah maybe next time
we'll have a past ruler or something uh
that was good
no I well it was okay but uh about Rick
Rick can get us back my game come on
Rick your turn you did yeah sounds all
right it was toys yeah whoo okay
we're on extraction
what the did you just say what did
you just say I invite you into
my home for game night I invite you to
my house and that's what you say guys
guys
it was transformers how the was
that transformers you know what I got a
good idea
why don't you transform into a bird and
fly out of my cool house huh
why'd you do that um okay you want that
bird to drop you off at one of the what
30 rehabs you're go to how they
goats with TMZ said right 30 set right
30 hey that's good acting
you don't belong here
Hollywood isn't for you losers pack up
and get the out walk yeah all right
you know what he up whoop-dee-doo
man he was nervous to be around you he's
your biggest fan
we both are okay that's a loyal friend
he would never sell a a tape are you
jerking off with a noose around your
neck you creep cuz he's a real
friend you should get some not like this
little dick brigade you got around you
or your whore model from Saturn I was
really good acting yep my phone's done
yeah I wish you would have just guessed
that it was transformers what's
seen in transformers was that dude it
was this scene at the very end with
Autobots hanging off the thing
by an extension cord Michael Bay
wouldn't a cop man oh thanks for
that speech man love your buddy broken
family putting the pieces back together
again